if I started from zero and had to get to
$110,000 per month as an email
copywriter as fast as possible then this
video is the stepbystep framework that I
would use to do it in less than 60 days
so I'm going to cover exactly what I
would do as well as what I would avoid
doing now this isn't just theory in fact
I actually launched my own email agency
a couple months ago and so I've been
savagely building up my monthly
recurring Revenue with that agency so
I've been testing these methods very
recently they're fresh on my mind and
I'm going to help you get to $10,000 a
month very quickly but before we dive
into the video I have a gift for you it
is my free copyrighting guide called
copyrighting Catalyst because as you are
growing that monthly income and adding
clients to your roster you're going to
need to figure out how to keep those
clients and the best way to keep clients
is by getting them results the best way
to get them results is be a damn good
copywriter so you're going to want to
get my free copyrighting guide it has 63
cash cow copyrighting tips that you can
read in 90 seconds or less each so that
you can sharpen your copyrighting skills
deliver amazing results and have them
handing you cash hand over fist so click
the link in the description below put
your email in it will come to your inbox
instantly with that said let's talk
about the step-by-step framework to
getting to $10,000 per month to me you
only have two routes okay you can either
build your own business or or you could
do done for you services for clients
okay so you can write emails for
yourself and sell your own products or
you can write emails for clients and
sell their products for the sake of
speed I'm going to write emails for
clients because writing emails for
yourself and selling your own stuff
takes way longer than 30 to 60 days okay
that is more like 3 to 6 years because
you have to build the product you have
to build the email list you have to
nurture the email list you have to do
sales all this stuff it's way too long
so if we want to go fast we want to go
to clients so now that we've got that
figured out let's talk about how we get
those clients because that is the only
thing you need to be focused on you
don't need to focus on building a
website or building an irresistible
offer blah blah blah blah blah all this
stuff that is all a waste of time the
only thing you need to work on is
getting clients Outreach communication
connection everything you do to get to
$10,000 a month is your ability to
connect with clients that's it
everything else is a waste of time now
this is a assuming you are a decent
copywriter you are a good copywriter you
have the fundamentals down you have some
skills if you do not please stop
watching this video this video is not
for you okay this is not some speed hack
for you to trick people into a get-rich
quick scheme this is assuming you have
skill was that a little brutal all right
sorry any who assuming you have skill we
need to move all of our attention to
client acquisition everything else is a
waste of time now we've got that out of
the way we need to figure out how many
clients do we need for $10 ,000 a month
you have two main routes to do this
route one is you can get two clients at
$5,000 per month or you could get four
clients at
$25,000 per month for the sake of speed
I would go for four clients at
$25,000 per month because it is going to
be way easier to close a client at a
lower monthly investment so we know that
we need to focus entirely on Outreach we
know that we are an email copywriter and
we know that we sell email copywriting
for $25,000 a month fantastic now we
have to find the clients that will buy
our email copyrighting and the best way
to do that is to find a hungry market
and right now as of the making of this
video there are three really hungry
markets for email copywriters the first
one I would say is e-commerce Brands
which is exactly what my email micro
agency dragu fitterman and Co does this
is a hungry Market that we have savagely
tapped into and I'm telling you that
because the playing field is that big
okay there could be a 100 more email
copywriters a thousand more enter this
space and there would still be enough
Ecom brands for everyone the other two
hungry markets that really demand email
copyrighting right now in 2025 is SAS
products and info products SAS is great
because they're always selling like free
trials it's a low monthly entry and so
you could get a lot of subscriptions
they're often running paid ads so they
email list is growing it's a fantastic
industry that needs email copywriters
the other one is info products people
like creators influencers YouTubers
coaches who are selling their courses
and curriculum and things like that
online the reason I love this Niche is
because there are so many of them as
well as the margins right they have very
low overhead unlike e-commerce which has
very high overhead a lot of YouTube
creators specifically are really good on
video but they're not great writers so
they have a skill set Gap I'm clearly an
anomaly where I'm a writer first a
YouTuber second but you could go scour
the interwebs of YouTube and go find
these people and go reach out to them
all right so those are your three hungry
markets to getting clients now here's
how I would reach out to them I would
make a personal list of the people you
genuinely want to work with grab a fi
notes like this a pen and paper Okay pen
and paper and write it down okay write
down who do you want to work with make a
list okay let's focus on info products
YouTube creators cuz let's just run with
that for this video write down 100
Youtubers that you like or that you
would like to work with genuinely people
that you could get along with a bonus
tip here is you should write for people
where you are the target audience for
example if you're into photography and
you like watching Peter McKinnon on
YouTube because you're a photographer
maybe put Peter McKinnon on your list of
people that you would connect with with
because it's going to be easier to write
emails for someone where you are the
target audience where you understand the
pains the hopes and the desires of the
people that he is writing for so it's
going to be a lot easier for you guys to
connect to get along to understand each
other this is the opposite of what all
the goons and gurus online tell you they
tell you to get a list of 5,000 people
and put it in LM list and automate your
emails and blah blah blah no one gives a
sh that whole efficiency and 5,000
emails and all that stuff that is Spam
okay that is not helpful to anyone and
it shows that you don't care about the
person that you're reaching out to it
shows that you're only trying to dig in
their pockets it's absolutely cold and I
think it's a terrible way to get clients
and honestly it makes you feel crummy
and terrible not to mention who cares if
you actually end up Landing those
clients people that you don't want to
work with you end up not matching
personalities they fire you 6 months
later it's a nightmare so you actually
want to build a list of people that you
would love to work with now you have a
list of 100 people that you would like
to work with the next thing you need to
do is you need to find their email oh
Ellen's going to tell us to cold email
yeah chill relax okay this is why we're
writing a list of 100 people that we
would love to work with because we're
going to make it personality based we're
not going to just send them spam easy
ways that I like to get emails is you
could use apollo.io and you could scrape
emails that way or you could hire
somebody on upwork or Fiverr to go
scrape emails for for you so now that
you have their email you reach out to
that person with a personalized email
and in that personalized email you're
going to tell them what you love about
them how long you've been following them
and a way that you can help them make
money now the drawback of this is you
cannot do it in 10 minutes a day or you
cannot set it up and fire it off no when
I do Outreach like this it takes like 20
to 30 minutes per Outreach okay getting
the email writing the personality
writing the emails I mean it takes time
to send Outreach like this but I tell
you it whoops the pants off the very
cold generic cold email template crap
that everybody else sends because I get
responses all day long even if they
don't work with me I've had so many
people respond back and be like dude
thank you so much first off this is kind
thank you for being a fan all this stuff
and actually what happens is I I end up
talking to these people who would have
never talked to me otherwise who I'm
actually genuinely big fans of and you
build a relationship regardless and that
is really meaningful because come down
the line maybe Peter and a couple years
does want to send emails who's he going
to think of he's going to think of the
super nice guy that sent him all this
stuff however long ago and I'm going to
be the first one in his mind and he's
going to reach out to me so you're
actually planting seeds every single day
I would rather you send three of those a
day for the next 3 months then 300 cold
crap emails a day for the next mon so
now you know how to reach out to them
you know how to send them emails you
know what to say now you got to go do it
okay you go send three a day for the
next 3 months and that is
270 emails that you would send
personalized emails all you need to do
is close four of those that's it when
they reply back and they say what do you
offer you say hey I can send you three
to five emails a week for $2,500 a month
it'll make you a lot more money than
that are you good and 250 of them will
say no I don't want it 10 of them will
say I'm super interested maybe three
four of them will buy that's perfect
that's all you need is three four so the
process is really simple but it's not
easy because it takes a lot of work to
do but imagine yourself watching this
video in 3 months you have four clients
making $10,000 a month if you don't
start today you will absolutely kick
yourself in the face for not doing that
in 3 months you're going to look back
and say wow I'm still working here at
this 9 to5 I hate it I'm not happy I'm
not making any money I wish I would have
sent three emails a day starting 3
months ago and I probably have four
clients right now don't do that so as
soon as you stop this video do exactly
what I told you go make some money I
know it works I literally just did it so
I bet it can help you too that's it
that's all you need to do you don't need
to worry about a brand a website a logo
a portfolio or whatever a blah blah blah
none of that stuff just get to work
start reaching out to people make a list
get their email send them personalized
stuff talk to them be a great human
being solve a problem and they will pay
I hope this video was helpful and if it
was please like the video below
subscribe to the channel and if you
really want to read my daily emails then
hit the link in the description below to
sign up at Allen dro.com I send a daily
email I give you tips like this all the
time I tell great stories and I help you
the copywriter become significantly more
successful in your career so I hope you
enjoyed if you found this video valuable
share it with a friend thank you so much
and I'll catch you on the next one write
it down okay 100 people I just don't I
don't understand understand how people
are
like I don't know it seems like a lot of
work I don't know is it is it that much
work that much work you take the pen you
take the book okay
one this person two the next you just do
that over and over okay look at your
YouTube history who have you
watched write the name down it's not
hard don't act like it's hard
okay sorry I'm a little fired up
[Music]